tout près de l'obélisque place de la
république à buenos aires s deux groupes
de manifestants se font face d'un côté
des antilles quarantaine qui demandent
la fin des mesures de restriction et de
l'autre des médecins et des infirmiers
qui exige davantage de moyens
les soignants en première ligne contre
le virus disent manquer de matériel et
craindre pour leur sécurité
nous demandons au gouvernement de
prendre soin de la santé des soignants
et de veiller à ce que les ressources
arrivent à temps et soit suffisante et
que chaque lieu abrite des espèces
d'isolement et de protection des
travailleurs
les halls mans justement le camp d'en
face ne veut plus nous voulons
travailler scandent des handi
quarantaine ils s'opposent aux mesures
de restriction de circulation en vigueur
dans le pays et considère le
prolongement du confinement comme une
mesure liberticide
ce qui a été décidé et irrationnel c'est
une chose de prendre des mesures de
santé publique
une autre de priver toute la nation de
sa liberté au cours de ce face à face
des affrontements ont éclaté entre pro
et anti quarantaine malgré
l'intervention de la police de médecins
au moins ont été blessées
face à l'accélération des contaminations
notamment à buenos ars où ils ont
quintuplé en deux semaines le président
argentin a décidé de prolonger le
confinement jusqu'au 7 juin